Operating systems play a really
important role in computer systems.
In fact, when we talk about computers,
we often say the operating system
running on a certain kind of computer,
a Windows machine, or an iOS device.
We're going to see that operating
systems play an extremely important and
critical role when it
comes to protecting and
securing resources that we
have in our computer systems.
So let's look at what
a computer system is actually.
So we actually start with the hardware.
Your hardware consists of a CPU,
perhaps you have memory,
and other IO devices, so
that's the hardware that we have.
Now if you wanted to use
the hardware directly,
it's going to be pretty difficult.
In fact no one does that.
What we really do is run
a really important program,
actually operating system
is kind of a program,
that handles the low level
hardware resources that we have.
So your operating system
may be Windows or
Android, or
a number of these operating systems.
What we generally start
with the hardware
run the operating system on
that device that we have.
And the applications that we directly
deal with, that we run on our systems,
so this could be your browser, let's
say, or this could be your mail client.
So these applications then actually
running on top of the operating system.
One way to think about this picture
that we have for a computer system is
that hardware is where we have
the real or physical resources.
We're going to run an operating
system to control access to those
hardware resources, and those resources
then are going to be made available to
the various applications that we have.
So, if any of the these resources
had to be protected in case
we have different
applications running here.
The reason the operating system plays
a really important role is because
the operating system gets
between these applications and
how they can access the resources.